mesdames messieurs bonsoir de mémoire
d'homme on n'avait jamais vu cela dans
la région un très violent orage de
montagne qui a duré près de deux heures
hier soir
et à l'issue duquel la fin du monde est
arrivée dans le camping du grand bornand
une petite station de haute-savoie en
moins de dix minutes un torrent de boue
a tout emporté comme ctu de paille
le bilan provisoire fait état de 20
morts et de 28 disparus
un orage très violent a éclaté hier en
fin d'après midi pendant deux heures et
sur une distance de plus de 4 km toute
la vallée d'annecy et arroser le torrent
sort de son lit provoquant une coulée de
boue en contrebas cette marée envahit
alors les rues du village de grand
bornand plus atteint le terrain de
camping caravaning temps des voitures
sont immédiatement balayé par le torrent
fou
ja je crois qu'on peut
on peut pas c'est en réalité ces moments
que la france allait tellement vite
c'est inimaginable sont imaginables
c'est je crois qu'on peut pas le
raconter
y'a pas de mots pour définir je crois
qu'il faut le vivre vision des
cauchemars au dessus du village qui
tente de lutter contre la boue des
dizaines d'arbres ou arrachées des
véhicules dévale toute la longueur du
terrain avant de se fracasser dans le
borgne
personne n'a jamais vu pareille
catastrophe même en 1936 ou un accident
similaire s'était produit dans la région
il n'y a pas de l'avis de paris vous par
imitation pareille catastrophe s'est pas
donnée au trône d'ailleurs la meilleure
d'octobre dans les communes voisines sur
le bandeau valait bien la route
départementale a été emporté sur sur
plusieurs centaines de mètres voire en
kilomètres un pont est emporté la route
était coupée à plusieurs endroits
alors que la route c'est routes
départementales et donc existe depuis
des bûchettes puis de 500 sauveteurs
venus de tout le département sont
mobilisés sur les lieux du sinistre
la croix rouge française participe au
plan orsec et assure l'hébergement et le
soutien psychologique des familles
rescapés une dizaine de forestiers des
gages à la tronçonneuse et troncs
d'arbres qui obstruent les torrents
bientôt 12 puis 14 et enfin 20 accords
sont retrouvés sur plusieurs kilomètres
en aval
à l'heure actuelle les sauveteurs
poursuivent leurs recherches
il reste une vingtaine de personnes
toujours portées disparues